ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from our temporary
studio here in la we have a new studio
that is being
um
built for us right now
um from the ground up and we're very
excited about it um we're spending 80
million dollars on it
and some people think say it's too much
i don't think it is it's a hotel
condo
podcast studio it's going to have
residential units we've partnered with
some of the biggest developers in the
world
uh to bring you this state-of-the-art
podcast studio
uh pool fitness center
uh
i think 400 residential units
about
350 hotel rooms
i believe like 50 to 100 suites
and then the rest beautiful rooms
um five restaurants
so it's very exciting
we're teaming up with a lot of the big
chefs mario batali oh
mario batali
from new york city if you remember
he was canceled because in his
restaurant he had a rape room where he
would like bring people in
but a phenomenal chef we've decided to
say hey are we god
no we're not
are you jesus christ do i look like
jesus christ i don't think so so we
reached out to him and said let's let
bygones be bygones come in here and
let's cook that squidding pasta up so
mario batali's first new restaurant in a
long time is going to be in our high-end
condo uh
podcast studio
before we start the show this is a very
sad thing that i want to talk about and
i didn't i didn't think i would ever
have to do this and this is a tragedy a
unique
human
tragedy and many of you
don't know this
because this information is being kept
from you you're being lied to
and i have a pretty good idea of who's
doing it
but
i must
i must come clean
about what i know
this is true
i can't
sleep at night
perpetuating a fraud
and that we know both of us know
is not true
joe rogan
passed away from the coronavirus last
week
um it killed him almost instantly
it was
very tragic
he had 17 strokes
an hour after testing positive
it was incredibly
sad
not only did it kill him
but
it was so
shocking
that young jamie
the producer of the joe rogan experience
okay
lost his mind
after joe was
after joe died of the
covet
young jamie went nuts
he went completely insane
and no one knows where he is right now
okay
this is
something that is being kept from you
by spotify
and
on it
the real illuminati
the supplement companies are keeping
this from you joe died
even though
he was taking all of the supplements
vitamin d
chrysaritin magnesium
all of them
he died instantly
he lost his mind before he died as well
he was not making any sense he
was he was in a chair
and his last words i swear to god
and this is sad
yeah it is very sad are we more relevant
in the podcast base now probably yeah
but this is very sad
his last words he was just screaming
ivermectin
as he was stroking out in a chair
i remember i remember
so
it's not right and it's sad
um but we have a uh
a memorium what do you call it an in
memoriam yeah like they play at the
oscars that's right
of of joe
that young jamie tried to move into his
house
and he walked in and he looked at joe's
wife and he said i'm the king now and
she shot him
so
this is what's going on in texas
so let's play the memorium here for
the man that's more responsible for our
career than any other really other than
me
but
it's sad it's sad it is not it is
unfortunate that this happened
and it is very sad the way young jamie
has handled this trying to steal joe's
wife and move into his house
it's crazy
it's completely absurd that this
behavior
i mean
so let's take a look at this uh montage
here
[Music]
it's a tough way to go
yeah it's rough well
he was fat
that's part of what people don't know he
smoked too his
every time he did that show he was in a
corset
his real size
would would i mean it would stun people
it was stunning
um
i i was a little late here i was
watching behind the mask on
hulu
about the uh
mascots have you watched that i have not
seen this show it's a it's it's uh
heartwarming
and it's about uh people that have very
little confidence maybe
um we all have our issues
but when they put on the suit they
become a god gotcha
right so i've been watching that it's
kind of interesting
when they put on the mascot costume
thousands of people cheer for them
but when they take it off they're
nothing again
and it's it makes for good viewing
because it's an interesting i think if
there's not many people in the world i
can relate to because there's not many
people who do my [ __ ] up job for a
living comedian or podcaster these guys
must feel like that that there's not a
ton of people who've ever felt that
power
of being the mascot
everybody loves you and no one knows who
you are
because you are behind the mask
the title of the show
and so i i'm i think i'm i'm in i'm on
episode two right now
i don't know how far i'll go
it just started playing
i didn't have any choice i just
i had hulu up in it
they just chose that for me they do that
sometimes they go here's what you'll
like
a show about uh people that are mascots
that only want to live
when they're in a very hot
sweaty
costume of a moose
that's the only way they can find
happiness on this planet and you would
really like that so
here we go and they were right because
i'm
watching i'm kind of hooked
i'm kind of hooked
uh very sad in new orleans someone
reached out to us on instagram
uh it's out of the news but the
hurricane ida
uh the name of our persian friend
uh
the hurricane in new orleans has knocked
out power and power has been out for
days
some places won't have it for a couple
weeks they won't get it back what i was
reading new york city uh the tail end of
ida uh
dumping torrential rain on new york city
killing a few people that got stuck in
their basements
i don't know how that works but
very sad new york city subways were
flooded
and a lot of those
images are
uh we're on twitter and you were just
scrolling and going man
i am so happy to not be there
you know
but
yeah the new york subway
is going to flood a lot and there's
nothing
we will do about it that's true yeah
welcome to the climate change era that's
what they're saying
well it's rain
listen is it climate change sure
but six inches in an hour is a is a ton
that's a lot i don't know it's not that
much at all really
you need six inches if you want to go an
hour
come on
are any of the people in new orleans
that are sitting in their houses without
power
and
scared to go out into the alligator
infested waters
and experiencing a failure of both state
and federal leadership do you think any
of them
are disappointed that they can't watch
the dimlio show on hulu
because
if you get your power back if you get
your power back
go
run don't walk
to the tv store
and buy a tv
and subscribe to hulu
and watch
the dimlio show it's a show
about charlie demilio a very sweet
young girl
perhaps medicated i don't know
but very
calm uh
and her family
uh she's got like what a trillion
followers on tick tock she's got more
followers on tick tock than people exist
on earth
and she's very successful and she's a
dancer and she's a sweet girl she's
truly sweet when you watch the show um
and her sister's a singer
and the parents are from connecticut and
the dad was a
republic shh
black lives matter
but the dad i think was a republican he
was a little bit of a
a connecticut republican which he what
that he's not a texas republican but he
was a connecticut republican oh yeah
that's right nothing wrong with that not
where we stand but
you know
it's probably not the best branding
angle
so you have him and the mother and then
the children
uh and it you know i mean
boring
right
let me this thing is so
boring
that your you know reality tv should be
fun and you realize how good the
kardashians were
uh they set a bar
man did those [ __ ] set a bar
i watched an earlier scene today where
kim and her mother were fighting and kim
was thinking of firing her mother as a
manager
and chloe went to the mother and goes
you know kim's meeting with other people
and chris cause who is she met with and
you go that's what i want i want a
family that regards each other with deep
suspicion i want a family that sees each
other mainly as brands
like when they sit around a table
that's fun to watch
it's fun to watch a family that lawyers
up against each other when need be
that's cool but the dimlio family it's
it's this you know you have these two
girls and then they have a again
700 000 million bazillion trillion they
have they have the population of china
following them on social media every
time they like wave
uh they get like 400 million you know
and then you know
the whole show is these two girls going
to their family going the internet is
mean
and you feel bad because i know it's
and
what happens is
like the family will be in the kitchen
they'll be like making dinner and then
one of the girls goes
the internet said i should kill myself
again
and then the parents are like well
that's hey
that's not nice
and they go she goes well
it's very sad
because people are saying that i should
be dead today
but instead of dying i uploaded a dance
video
and the parents like well if this isn't
good for the kids
we'll get out of here
and the kids are literally like today
someone else said i should be burned
alive
and then you cut to the parents going if
at any time this is bad for the kids
we'll get out of here we're not we don't
want to ruin our family for money
they said that i should be burned like a
witch
they said i'm nothing
well
listen
just ignore it
dad sometimes i can't ignore it
the thoughts just stay in my head and i
just cry
just ignore it
if any if at any moment me and my wife
think it's a bad idea
for millions of people to tell my
daughter to kill herself
on the internet
we'll move out of here
we'll go back to connecticut i used to
sell uh
shorts
he's like
he sold athleisure where
you know he's a fun guy too
sometimes i make fun of people on the
show and i go i would love to be friends
with a republican from connecticut who
sold like uh sports apparel
it's just a fun type of person yeah he
looks fun
he's a fun guy
and uh but i i love that angle of like
if ever it gets too much for the kids
and literally there's a scene where the
girl is crying like every moment of
every day every
minute of a lot every minute i'm alive
they tell me to kill myself and he's
like listen just come in here and vent
whenever you need
so i just it's just
they should play that up more in the
editing but they don't and it's just a
very boring show and you know you
realize that children are boring and
stupid now i don't mean they're not
crafty and savvy because they are these
kids are going to have empires they've
got uh ring lights and target they've
got uh
clothing lines
they've got number one hit singles
number one hit singles uh they are
dominating so i don't mean they're not
savvy i don't mean that they don't work
hard but
they're they're kids right so what we
can't what
the kardashians were never children they
were never children which made them
entertaining they were never children
and they were never a family and that's
what's great about it
kris jenner was never a mother they
called her the momager i mean she was a
[ __ ] powerhouse i want to watch
powerhouses i want to watch that demilio
mother grab one of the girls by the hair
and go shut the [ __ ] up you want to go
work at the gap because that's the real
answer the real answer when these girls
start crying and i know the internet is
mean and i know they say horrible things
they've said them to people who said
nasty things about me even even me
um
but the answer to them is do you want to
work at the gap
do you want to work at the gap
if not we got to power through this
as a family but i i hope that this show
gives some comfort to the people in new
orleans who are suffering
right now with the no power and the
flood i hope that eventually they can
get the power back on to watch this very
very boring and incredibly unnecessary
show it's incredibly unnecessary uh to
see behind the scenes of nothing because
it's nothing right there's absolutely
nothing going on um the kardashians
are more important than the bushes
clintons obamas and trumps in terms of
american culture but this family it's
just not that they're sweet kid the
girl's a sweet girl and i feel bad that
people on the internet keep telling her
to die
uh that's not nice but uh
you don't need a behind the scenes
you've never watched a tick tock it went
but what's really going on it's it's
unnecessary unless it gets bad
that's the thing like you know when the
dad goes
if it ever gets you know too much but
that but that's what we want to see is
too much
too much is good
for the show
they bring like grandma in and grandma's
sitting there and
it's very interesting
because this girl's like the girl next
door she was a dancer she just popped
blew up good for her
and uh
i have no
i just i don't want anyone i don't want
anyone to be unhappy or go through
something painful right but it does make
for better television
uh undeniably so
you know they had a whole scene where
charlie couldn't find her can opener
when i when i left when you were
watching it she was like she couldn't
find the can opener for two minutes and
that was the whole right that was the
big drama of the scene so i mean that's
kind of
if one
if the older sister killed the younger
sister
ramsay style
jonbenet
ramsey stop then we'll do season two
but until then
let's cut the [ __ ] we don't need the
show
it's unnecessary yeah
that's all i'm saying unlike the power
of new orleans which is
necessary like we should
have it you know i mean i i imagine
i love sheath underwear it's great it is
perfect it has a
pouch for your balls
uh and your penis
and that's what people want now because
you don't chafe and it's great and
sheath underwear dot com use promo code
tim to save 20 it's so intricate do you
know
who the owner of this company is
uh robert patron right
do you know his story i know he's like a
veteran you want to talk about an
inspiring story
like a like a guy who like literally
is like crazy inspiring
like teddy roosevelt like a guy like
that or
kind of
this guy
robert patron
is a veteran
of the armed forces
do you know what his why are you
laughing
do you know what his job was
while he was deployed in iraq and
afghanistan i don't
his job
was to entrap
important figures
by providing them children to have sex
with do you know what a hard job that is
do you know how morally compromising
that is yeah giving
these
important figures that we need to
blackmail
children to rape and in some cases
murder but he's saving lives at the same
time but it's saving lives because he's
getting the we blackmail them to get the
info that keeps us safe
right yeah
fight them in
provide them with children abroad
so you don't have to fight them at home
robert patron sheath underwear dot com
promo code tim to save 20
i mean it's not hey anyone can go over
there and like shoot a bad guy
i mean anyone can do that but what's
really difficult is kidnapping children
and then providing them
to warlords that we need to blackmail uh
while they and he would have to stand
outside while the warlords raped and
murdered the kids
but
that's real to me
that's real patriotism yeah yeah it's
not the type of patriotism uh that a lot
of people have where they're just flag
waving
this guy actually did the work
and we respect sheath underwear.com
promo code tim
bird dog shorts shorts with a built-in
silky soft inner liner that makes
underwear obsolete they are the most
comfortable shorts i have ever worn and
it's not even close you don't even have
to wear underwear you want to pull your
dick out it goes right from the bird
dogs right into the environment baby
they stole lululemon's designer and now
they're doing it better if you're not
wearing bird dogs december what the [ __ ]
are you even doing every dude needs a
pair of bird dogs
i'm talking like a bro right now but
that's not it's not that yeah yeah you
know what i mean
it's not like that
it's something else
but it it had
it the the inside of these shorts is
soft yes it's like you're being jerked
off
or fingered in your [ __ ]
do you get fingered ever no i don't i
love being fingered because what it
reminds you is that everything in your
body can work in many different ways
you understand yes
your lack of imagination
exists because you're unwilling
to use everything
in every way
it's crazy that you've never fingered
yourself i've never fingered never put a
finger in your [ __ ] while you came no
i have not do you know how much more
intense the orgasm is i've heard i have
friends that tell you so much you never
go back yeah you well you do go back
sometimes because not everyone wants to
do that you legally have to go back you
can't just jam a thing it's you know
bird dogs are a good short because it's
soft and people love it they really
enjoy it if if i see someone that
doesn't have bird dogs on i go hey man
what the [ __ ] are you doing
with your life
you know
everybody has bird dogs they're
they're cool i've been wearing these
they're nice they're cool
doesn't anyone want to be cool anymore
for [ __ ] christ's sake
doesn't anyone want a [ __ ]
uh your friend goes dude what kind of
shorts are they that's not gay at all
but you do suck each other off
later
because you have bird dogs on he's like
dude what kind of shorts are they
how do they keep your dick you'd be like
that's kind of gay but you don't really
mind that he asked that and then you
suck each other off later
and you're both married
it's weird as [ __ ]
you don't even know if you like you just
hate your [ __ ] wife that stupid [ __ ]
you don't even like
but his dick's not that big so it fits
in your mouth and you you swallow this
[ __ ] because you do a good job you you
want to work
you work you're not brilliant but you
work
so you suck your friend's average to
less than average-sized dick and you
want your wife to see it you wish that
she had a dream and you saw him you you
swallowing his [ __ ] because you hate that
[ __ ] and her father's money and she
holds it over your goddamn head that
you're a near do well and you're so so
[ __ ]
your kid's not that bright and she knows
she made a big mistake with you but you
were the only one that cared about her
after her breakup so every now and then
you go suck off your friend who's really
gay and enjoys it and he likes it
because it's forbidden
and it's hot not so much to you you
don't really like it in fact you've
thought about not doing it and you would
not do it except for your stupid wife
who's ruined your life you want to look
at her one day at dinner and say i suck
[ __ ] and you want it to be real you
could say that but you want it to be
real you want to feel the pubic hair in
your throat because she's such a [ __ ]
and what bird dog shorts do
is they allow you
to get into situations like that that
are not gay you just
you hooked up with the wrong woman it's
not gay to spite suck off your friend
because your wife is a [ __ ]
did bird dogs do it again or did bird
dogs do it again go to birddogs.com
enter promo code tim dillon and they'll
throw in a free bird dog's whistle ball
you remember those nerve vortex howler
footballs that whistle when you throw
them yeah it's that but bird dogs threw
their logo on it genius that's
birddogs.com promo code tim dillon and
boom a free bird dogs whistle ball while
you're with your pair of bird dogs you
will not take these things off i promise
you but your friend will
you read an interesting article about
the ice cream machine at mcdonald's
they're doing a deep dive into this yeah
so the ftc is like sending letters to
owners of franchises yeah we don't know
where covet came from but we're doing a
deep dive into why the ice cream
machines at mcdonald's seem to be broken
more often than when they're working
the priorities are skewed
mcdonald's said in a statement to the
globe that the company quote has no
reason to believe we're the focus of an
ftc investigation the company said it as
a team working on the ice cream issue
the ice cream issue
and it is deploying solutions
such as new training for employees and
regular maintenance checkup on the
machines
we've been at mcdonald's a lot yeah at
night and what happens they usually say
the machine is down and a lot of them
say it's for cleaning
but we know that's not the case some of
them are honest and go we don't know why
it's down
it's like
during the power grid failures uh uh uh
uh when gray davis was the governor of
california oh yeah and was just forcing
the power grids to go down uh to jack
the price of power up this is kind of
what's happening at mcdonald's they
forced the machine to go down
um on a smaller scale but maybe not i
don't know
and uh my problem with mcdonald's and
this is with a lot of things by the way
it's not only mcdonald's a lot of the
whether it's a mcflurry or a blizzard or
a concrete anything where it has ice
cream and then candy mixed through it
and you could tell me if i'm wrong when
i grew up the candy was swirled through
the entire
thing
now it is best case the top 25 are
toppings the bottom is ice cream
and i don't know why that is
one of the one of the creepiest things
i've ever seen the mcflurry machine was
broken and uh i was in pennsylvania i
had done a show years ago and i stopped
into a rest stop mcdonald's
which means it's a mcdonald's but
there's also
bathrooms for the truckers to
and then there's get some head
and then there's also like a gift shop
for i don't know
like a postcard that says pennsylvania
um
and it's for human traffickers and
people that need to take a piss and i
walked in i ordered a mcflurry and they
didn't have one so she hand flurried it
she took this spoon
and just like in front of you she just
she just and she this is what was spooky
she never broke eye contact with me
while she was hand flouring it as if to
say
this is my life
she just locked eyes with me and it was
an oreo mcflurry
and and and she just was like stabbing
it with the spoon
and
and i and it was a good 30 seconds
of
unbroken eye contact with this uh
monster really
and she was just kind of flurrying it by
hand and then she just put it on the
counter
and walked away
i don't know if that was like the lowest
point in her life or if that if she was
angry that i ordered a mcflurry or
i don't get it i don't understand it but
that's something i remember
but people are getting angry
uh at mcdonald's because people have had
enough
the things that we really
we demand in this country are
interesting at issue could be the
relationship mcdonald's has with taylor
commercial food service a company that
makes most of its ice cream machines the
journal reported that the machines which
make milkshakes soft serve ice cream and
the mcflurry
require a quote nightly automated heat
cleaning cycle that can last up to four
hours to destroy bacteria
if that process doesn't work owners must
call a technician before they can use
the machine so there is some science
behind the answer that it's down for a
cleaning
so the science is that they're trying to
destroy the bacteria in the ice cream
machine so it's up for 20 hours and then
down for four and then it should be back
up for another 20.
every day on a cycle but it should be
down
but see a lot of mcdonald's are in 24
hours oh yeah that's right so you know
sometimes the four hours it's down it's
like 11 12. i mean i'm like hey man
what are we doing this is prime time
this is prime time for the mcflurry but
people don't care
people don't give a [ __ ] there was
another scene in the demilio thing where
they were eating hibachi now you like
hibanji i like him i've never in my life
had fun at a hibachi place it's kind of
fun to go out is it fun the they do the
volcano with the onion you don't find it
a little demoralizing
that the chef has to do that i think he
likes it he likes making a volcano out
of onions some of them seem cheery when
they do it they like doing the flips a
lot of people seem cheery when they're
doing things that they hate
i don't like it because the number one
the food none of it's good it's true
none of it's when you get the food you
go ah
it's overcooked shrimp
that was thrown in the air yes it's not
good yeah i also don't like
that
there's people excited
about
like the guy doing tricks with uh rice
and onions and it's odd to me and i hate
the way you all sit
like it's a show it feels like you're at
sea world watching like the
the sea lions
but you like that that's something about
it you you like you get to sometimes you
get to meet an interesting couple from
across the table
at the hibachi yeah yeah what do you
consider interesting what are you and
your wife considering well okay god help
us i think the last time i went out in
austin to a hibachi grill which was one
time there was a guy that was uh filming
the uh guy do the choo choo train what
the hell is the choo-choo trick so what
they do is they have the you know if
anyone said to me you want to go to a
botch i would not i would like
take them out of my phone i would delete
their number it's just the most like
a basic [ __ ] like to me
saying like
i want to like it would be like it would
be it's it's this bad right yeah yeah
you you're going to dinner with someone
to go hey why don't we go
instead of dinner they go like this and
go why don't we go to a homeless shelter
at night and i'll help out
like you get that text in the car you go
what you don't know how to respond right
you don't want to do it
but you you can't just be like hey [ __ ]
that
but
that's the tabachi text you're like oh
let's do hibachi go
hey man no
i don't want to do that
so you met a guy that was in the choo
choo train is what again
uh so you know how they usually do the
volcano with smoke coming out oh yeah we
know sometimes they have the train
whistle which is those long wooden
whistles when you blow through it it
sounds like a train whistle yes and then
he moves it to make it look like a train
is going and usually the little kids
start you know they like it but this a
grown man was just filming it with his
phone i don't want to go to any
restaurant where children are uh happy
i never want to see a happy child at a
restaurant i want to see miserable
children sitting there
angry put now you have the technology
just give them the phone put the kid on
the phone yeah put the kid on the phone
the big ipad let the kid figure out who
they are and what they believe while you
have dinner
you don't need to entertain the kids
with hibachi anymore do kids even like
hibachi they just want to be on [ __ ]
gaming and [ __ ] they want the shirley
temple and then the rice and you pour
all the ginger sauce on it that's what
ugh
it sounds
heinous
it's never good dude the food is never
good but when you the food at habanshi
place when you get it
it's kind of like you feel like
like a refugee
it's like rice and over cup cooked
shrimp and like an onion that's how they
feed it to you at the end they throw the
shrimp into your mouth yeah i don't want
that where everyone opens their mouth
like birds
and then he goes around and i don't want
that
someone could choke to death like that
that's an at-risk activity
it's not right
but
whatever i have a specific set of
circumstances that i
i like i like restaurants we're starting
to develop an elderly fetish
me and you aren't we i can think a
little bit i we really like elderly
people like i like elderly people
i like them
they're slow yeah you know they're
they're always looking to get the better
of you you have to watch them they will
cut you have to watch them and there's
something i like about that it keeps me
on my toes
but they're slow enough
and physically diminutive enough where
you can like if you had to beat one of
them up you could yeah you're like i
could throw this guy against a wall
like i was in a walgreens and i cut i
didn't cut i just wanted change
i wanted like change of a 20. i'm like
okay and then the old guy behind me said
hey there's a line here and what was
nice about it i was like i could turn
around and whack this guy in the head
right now she was elderly i'm like i
could [ __ ] this guy up
he's not like a big
strapping in shape guy i'm like i could
turn around right now and just
[ __ ] smack this 83 year old
right across his face
i didn't
but it's nice to know that you could
he's also probably might have beat the
[ __ ] out of me he's some like war
veteran he's some old nazi
some old florida nazi
that just knows how to [ __ ]
gavin newsom is going to survive this
recall in california
there was a machete attack
in malibu yes and i i i don't like
machete attacks but i love alliteration
machete
malibu
um family of fi and by the way i don't
want to be i don't want to like
want to hear a story like this i don't
know who i agree with right away
you know
like the last thing i want to do i'm not
a prude i realize every now and then you
got to take out the knife the big knife
i don't know what's going on here it
says dad loses eye
hey it seems i wanna let's digest
all of the facts
do you promise
we digest all of the facts before we
make a snap judgment
on the on these two homeless people
attacking a family with a machete
los angeles county got an argument
between a dad
and two homeless people on a beach in
malibu took an extremely violent turn
over the weekend ending with the father
losing an eye
well here's my first thoughts
my first thoughts of this
if you're with your family
and you're
and you're like in an argument walk away
don't push
right yeah don't keep pushing
um
nobody is happy now
when you've lost an eye
the family is
traumatized beyond belief
now
i am an advocate
for
people
getting a
full hearing so i want to know what
happened here i'm not i'm not just going
to take the reactionary stance
that a machete attack on a family is
wrong
i'm not going to do it people want me to
do it but i love california
this is a very complex place with a lot
of layers
and we must always dig deep
to find out what
went on
the los angeles county sheriff's
department responded to a call on dan
blocker beach on sunday deputies were
told a man with four family members
when they were approached by two
suspects both believed to be homeless
the two suspect the two homeless people
confronted the dad saying they were not
allowed in the area sparking an argument
between the three people one of the
suspects later identified as whoever i
don't want to say their name whipped at
a machete and began slashing the dad
multiple times
both suspects were found and arrested
they're being charged with attempted
murder i mean the moral of the story is
this if you're on a beach in malibu and
two homeless people tell you to leave
and you're with your family it's not
about being tough it's not about winning
the fight it's about
my kids and my wife are here
and i gotta get uh away right from that
you know now some people would say
homeless people shouldn't live on a
beach with machetes
that is not my position
and i want to be clear about that
i want to be clear
about this
saying
that homeless people with weapons
shouldn't live on the beach
would make me a lunatic
you understand
because where are they going to go that
would be the answer that would be the
question they go where are they going to
go
where are they going to go with their
machetes where are they going to go
well the vast majority of homeless
people don't have machetes tim
that is correct
thank you progressive friend
most of them don't have machetes and
they don't take people's eyes out
thankfully that is true do you think
they well where are they gonna go
i don't know
are you saying that homeless people
shouldn't set up communities
that become open-air fentanyl markets
where uh people occasionally get weapons
and kill each other i'm saying there
should be a better way housing i don't
know
shut up
okay
it's a crisis
i don't know how this is uh happening
the state of california doesn't build
any [ __ ] homes the cost per unit to
build homes is absurdly high
i don't know that's probably
environmental or system regulation or
whatever
they're setting fires to homeless people
and here's the problem i find that funny
this is why it's hard to be a comedian
and a human being
do you understand
sometimes being a comic and being human
are diametrically opposed to each other
because as soon as i hear a homeless guy
starting a fire we laugh uncontrollably
we've been in the car so many times and
as soon as because i imagine the way it
happens
and i don't know if this is true but i
imagine it's kind of a sneak you know
it's like a guy who looks like this he
like looks both ways and then oh and
then it starts a fire and then i feel
like he just like scurries away to watch
it that makes me laugh no i don't think
it's good but it's funny it shouldn't
happen but i like it a little you know
what i mean
it's funny what if we found out the
demilio family was starting these fires
then i'd watch the show what if charlie
dimiglio was starting fires all over los
angeles she was a pyromaniac
and that was because she she said so
much of my life is out of my control and
the only thing i can control is these
fires and i can start these fires so
late at night i leave my house and i
start fires with homeless people in
malibu that would be amazing
perhaps revolutionary
but i don't know if she's doing that but
what if she was doing that
would i
support her and the answer is
probably but that would make it a very
interesting uh
show
malibu uh continues to worsen more
crimes and fires have been reported
recently all stemming from transients in
the area
this is fox news fox 11 news at 10.
um
the community is holding a meeting
thursday night to discuss public safety
concerns in malibu man i really am angry
that i didn't go to that meeting
because i wanted to go to that meeting
can you imagine me
i would love to go to that meeting
hello
many of you know me i've lived in the
community for years i wouldn't even say
my name i would just say many of you
know me
many of you know me i've lived in the
community for years
malibu is a special place
god i wish i went i just look around and
go malibu is a special place that's why
we're all here because it's special
getting him you know i'd get emotional
i'd be like it's because it's special
and i'd look you know get that look and
let's stare at the people and i go
god damn it
i'm sorry but i'm [ __ ]
i'm mad
i'm angry
we don't let fires push us out
we don't let traffic stop us
but we got these [ __ ] freaks with
machetes and i'm gonna say freaks
they've got machetes they're an army of
freaks and they're cutting out people's
eyes
and i'm i'm here to say no
i'm drawing the line
you can't cut my eye out
i'm a good [ __ ] person
and if i want to tell everybody in this
room something
right now
at one time in my life
i was homeless
it was a weekend in the early 90s
my parents had asked me to leave their
home in montecito because i was quote
acting erratically
well what was a young man to do
out in the world alone
with a valium problem i was taking my
mother's valium
among other things
my mother is also a drug addict but it
doesn't matter i guess
because whatever
so i went down to los angeles
or up to los angeles
and i tried to stay with a friend of
mine
but it turned out they were out of town
so i slept in my car for a night
down by venice beach back in the days
when it was safe to sleep in your car as
a white drug addict who was kicked out
of his house in montecito
i didn't get my eye cut out i got my
dick sucked
by a woman or man it doesn't matter i've
been to therapy
no one's perfect and we don't have to
figure everything out about ourselves
but sleeping in that car
it was october it was still pretty
toasty
i was given a fish taco by a local bar
well i took it and didn't pay
the point is they didn't call the cops
there was a sense of community back then
when a drug addict from montecito
could go drive down to venice or drive
up to venice steal a fish taco and get
his dick sucked
uh by someone still figuring out their
gender
i had a little cash i probably could
have afforded a hotel room but there was
something about sleeping in my car that
excited me
well the next day
i decided to strike it out on my own
i left my car and started wandering
around i had taken some pretty strong
acid
the majority of that day is still a blur
to me
i remember
knocking over a porto potty because i
thought it was a robot
but not once was my eye taken out by a
machete-wielding freak
okay
i woke up on the beach sunday morning i
got in my car and i drove home to my
parents and i promised them that i would
i would do my own drugs and i wouldn't
steal theirs anymore
and i said i would i would go to the
club
and not be drunk
and then i would i would i would go to
yale and i didn't want to be an artist
anymore and it was the best decision of
my life because artists are weird
very strange people
i can do weird sex [ __ ] and not be
creative and i learn that from a lot of
businessmen
so i just want to say at this community
meeting in malibu
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man
i want a [ __ ] i was a homeless man
and i i want to say this and my daughter
disagrees with me and i don't care and i
still call her my daughter i don't care
what her instagram says
i'm telling you right now we need to
kill these people and light their
corpses on fire thank you that's all i
have to say that's what i would have
said that's what i would have said and
it would have been great and i think it
would have moved hearts and minds that's
that's what i would have said but i
unfortunately
i did not get a chance to speak at the
malibu board meeting now is the time to
celebrate the nfl is finally back and
draftkings the official daily fantasy
partners of the nfl has millions of
reasons why you should be excited to
kick off football seasons draftkings is
giving new customers a free shot at a
one million dollar top prize with four
million dollars up for crabs that's
amazing a total of four million up for
grabs for thursday tonight's opener
whenever getting in on thursday night's
single game showdown is easy drive six
players from the season opener stay
under the salary cap and see how your
team stacks up against the competition
so head to the app now
feel the nfl action like never before
with a free shot at a million dollar
play day
payday
download the draftkings app now and use
promo code tim dillon this this week new
customers can get a free shot at a one
million dollar top prize
it's almost like i just said this but
it's so important i'll say it again
four million dollars in total prizes
enter code tim dillon to get a free shot
at the one million dollar top prize with
your first deposit that's code tim
dillon only at draftkings.com
the official daily fantasy partners
partner of the nfl
minimum five dollar deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details
when simply saves home security founders
chad and eleanor lawrence designed their
first security system in their kitchen
they did it for a very personal reason
their friends had just had their home
broken into
they were struggling to find a security
system
that was simple to set up and would make
them feel safe again
making people feel safe is what simply
safe has been doing since that moment 15
years ago
a passion to protect people not only
drives every engineering detail in its
products but it motivates every
interaction with its customers and the
thing is simply safe just makes it so
easy it takes about two minutes to
customize a system on their website
simply safe has highly trained security
experts ready whenever you need them
whether that's during a fire a burglary
a medical emergency or even when you're
just setting up the system there's
always someone there who has your back
to keep you safe and make sure you feel
safe
as my listener you can save 20 on your
simply safe security system and
get your first month free when you sign
up for interactive monitoring service as
my listener you can save 20
on your simply safe security system and
get your first month free when you sign
up for interactive monitoring service
just visit
simplysafe.com tim dillon that's
simplysafe.com tim dillon to customize
your system and start protecting your
home and family simply safe.com
tim dillon simplysafe.com
tim dillon had fun last night at the
comedy store
uh performing there the audience is
great tonight uh
hollywood improv well that by the time
you see this that will have passed
uh corpus christi texas right please buy
tickets to these shows folks
corpus christi texas what is corpus
christi tech just please buy tickets to
the goddamn show september 9th 10th and
11th
september 9th 10th and 11th it's
the weekend
of
9 911
hot ticket
tim dillon in corpus christi texas
weekend of 911 man that is a hot
ticket
i'm at mesquite
street
comedy i don't know what that is
but i i'm going to be there
it's a pizzeria where i believe there's
comedy
good
we're announcing a big theater tour next
week we're going to all the places
that you always say we should go
we're doing it we're finishing out the
year here with a great tour
and we're very excited we're announcing
it uh next week because our agent says
that we can't announce it after labor
day because it's a wash
[Music]
uh but we're announcing it and we're
very excited about it and if you haven't
seen uh this show live it's
it's a great show it's not we're not we
don't do the podcast live it's stand up
but ben will be on most of the dates we
might bring him out on on stage in the
theater and whatever
um also the beacon which ben will be at
the beacon and he will be on stage
because in addition to stand-up comedy
at the beacon theater we're doing a live
podcast at the beacon theater in new
york city on the upper west side of
manhattan we've sold well over 2 000
tickets but there are tickets left to
the beacon if you want to come and be a
part of uh
uh his story
his story
history his story uh you want to be a
part of it it's going to be a lot of fun
it's going to be uh exciting we might
try to get ray kump
up there
we're going to really try to do things
for the uh live show we wanted to
interview rogan but he's dead now
so what am i gonna do
with all of that what else is going on
in the world by the way did you see this
in the atlantic what else were you
speaking you were talking about
something earlier today did you see this
in australia what they have to do with
the uh the australians have lost it this
is in south australia specifically look
at this right here whatever
let me tell you something right now
whatever
disturbs you about the australian
lockdown they like it
they don't care they're building forts
in their houses
i keep reading that four and five are
like for the lockdown they really do
like they want it they like um if you
told those people they don't have to go
to work
it's like walking into a a clinic of of
uh anorexics and going no food today
ladies it's
i mean i mean and man i'm sure there's
male anorexia
but that's what it is
it's walking into a clinic of anorexics
and going you're not gonna believe this
but there's a storm coming we can't uh
grubhub anything and the oven's broke so
we're going without tonight
they're thrilled the people in australia
are thrilled by this they're building
forts in their house drunk
the state will text them at random times
and therefore they will have 15 minutes
to take a picture of their face in the
location where they're supposed to be
this is straight up black mirror who
knew australia
they're the healthy country they eat
grilled vegetables and shrimp
they're they're the country that's going
this crazy
quote i think every south australian
should feel pretty proud that we're the
national pilot for the home base
quarantine act
they've lost their minds you know my
aunt's lost her mind i told her at covid
they were on vacation she just wouldn't
stop talking about covet and then she
started talking about uh women in
afghanistan
it's so predictable the boomer brain
bleed is very predictable
like the boomers like uh it's like the
you program the boomer you know covet
covet is here new strains are coming
women in afghanistan cannot read this is
after 15 years of not paying any
attention to afghanistan having no
thoughts about it yeah but now they're
she's offended at the women
afghanistan because boomers need a
that in
tragedy they need you cannot go through
a dinner or a weekend without a tragedy
so
covid will come up and then if not
covert they go you know women in
afghanistan are having their [ __ ]
slobbed and you're like can we eat a
[ __ ] lobster roll we're on summer
vacation can you stop
when you don't give a [ __ ] about the
women in afghanistan can you stop
playing around
i don't know that many women in
afghanistan i probably don't even get
along with them i don't get along with
that many women in america
i'm not saying you should have their
[ __ ] slobbed off but i'm also you know
this newfound uh we're old sorry for the
women in afghanistan
and i don't agree that they banned
abortion in texas at like 3 a.m and now
they have this new law where you have to
inform and rat on people
this is the republicans love rats too
man this idea that only liberals are
rats
informing uh
on anybody
private health individuals including
anti-abortion activists with no
connection to patients can now be sued
i'm sorry anti-abortion activists with
no connection to patients can now sue
anyone who they believe is providing
abortion or assisting someone in
accessing abortion after six weeks this
could include healthcare workers clergy
rideshare drivers so just hey and then
there's like some some part of the law
where they'll give you a ten thousand
dollar bounty or something so you're
supposed to be hunting down
members oh here
the law doesn't just allow these
lawsuits it actively encourages private
individuals to act as bounty hunters
awarding them at least ten thousand if
they're successful so if you rat on
someone that's providing someone an
abortion it's six and a half weeks seven
weeks whatever
you get ten thousand dollars this is
this flies in the face of all of
all these people like just stop the
ratting stop ratting on your friend who
ran into the
capital dome stop ratting period mind
your [ __ ] business this flies in the
face of that
this flies in the face of that
completely not only is it a restrictive
law that uh restricts import no listen i
don't know
there's so many pills and condoms now
you should be able to kind of avoid but
a lot of women don't know they're
pregnant within six weeks you have a
wife
what is the deal with that with getting
pregnant
sort of yeah
no but people know they're saying i
don't i don't
i can't be involved with these with
what's happening here most women i've
never gotten uh someone pregnant
never
never a uh i was scared
i there was this scare
there was a scare not that i'd gotten
someone pregnant but then i accidentally
performed an abortion
because i fought a pregnant woman once
but so there was a scare but the baby is
fine a little slow when you talk to him
but fine
what i'm saying is
you have sex with your wife does she get
pregnant all the time and do you flush
him
why doesn't she get pregnant
uh you have the ovulation app that you
track so you know when a woman is uh if
they're not on the pill then you know
when they're going to ovulate so that's
a there's a a small window when a woman
can actually get pregnant and that
doesn't mean you should uh play games or
roll the dice but you but uh
a woman should be able to track these
things at this point women can only get
pregnant for a small window yeah when
they're ovulating
you know all we hear is how magical
these women are i don't i don't get it
trans women can get pregnant whenever
i should get pregnant
i should have a baby yeah like implanted
in me can that happen uh not that i've
seen uh i saw pete buddha judge and uh
chaston just had two babies well but
there adopted them i could adopt a kid
that's [ __ ] easy yeah who wants that
i want my own genes passed through i'm
gonna give a [ __ ] about some kid that
needs a home i'm talking about passing
on my [ __ ] talent
i need a kid that's gonna do this show
when i'm dead in three years
what what what what are we gonna i don't
care about adopting a kid some sad sack
of [ __ ] whose drug addict mother
couldn't keep him i want my own [ __ ]
jeans my [ __ ] talent
i gotta find a surrogate yeah
legit
i gotta find a surrogate to to groom an
air a successor to this patreon dynasty
what kind of woman would you choose
very good looking
southern knows your place
obedient
not bright
a big
blonde
[ __ ] southern woman yeah a trad wife
a trad wife uh suburbs of dallas
ding dong
big tits yeah
not a thought in her head
because nothing would get in the way of
my genes
she would just provide the physical
infrastructure
for my genes to get passed to the child
so he could yell and scream
now chasing and chasing and big
who's his name big buddha bigglesby
buddha judge is having what kind of kids
do they have
are they white let's see the picture is
black and white i wonder if that was
intentional of course it was what kind
of children are what is the race of the
children hmm
my godson is half asian we should get
him on the show
i want my godson to come in here right
now he's a quarter chinese
do you know i found that out
he is a quarter his mother is half
chinese he's a quarter chinese that's
great news i want him to be half
i want him to be
penelope rose and joseph august hmm
what does that mean what do you think
you can see the tips of their heads here
they look like white babies to me i'm
saying bring him to the studio in weho i
want to put this asian on the on on the
uh he's a killer he's very cute
they look white to me i don't know about
know what you're thinking well i'm happy
for them i mean listen good for them the
cia
also needs children oh they're also
parents to two dogs truman and buddy ugh
by the way if you have more than two
dogs cut it out
right like did the millions have four or
five dogs cut it out with that
it's it's a zoo
two dogs and that's enough and that's
too much yeah not five or six dogs
there's something wrong
right yeah i mean i mean the one person
we know has six dogs is you know
michelle
oh well now but michelle keeps killing
them you know michelle they remember
remember her maid killed the dog
oh yeah her maid killed that little dog
the great thing about michelle is
michelle because she's such a bad
uh parent of the animals is that every
year or two one of them dies so that's
good
because it keeps them down
uh keeps the numbers down but you know
over five dogs is just ridiculous i
think whitney has five at this point you
know whitney doesn't even know what's
going on
you know i mean it's like
i mean talk about ivermectin
how that that one
she's like making fun of she was like i
was on a phone or she's like talk about
ivermectin being for horses i'm like
your whole thing is horses
that's your whole thing
shouldn't you be supportive of this
how can i find you sorry if you let's
get a surrogate from me on the show
well it said they were trying for a year
to adopt so i think it's going to be
easier to do a surrogate than adopting
because adopting takes a bit here's the
reason that it's harder for them to
adopt
it's because
like
i think adoption is very difficult in
this country anyway
but i think i would be able to adopt
because i have the profile of someone
that you want raising a child
you understand
some i'm not gay i just have sex with
men i'm not gay
i'm not in the government i don't work
for the central intelligence it's weird
that because he works for the cia of
course uh and it's odd that he they you
know
they can't just give him one of the mk
kids but nobody wants that right nobody
wants some drone at breakfast some
rosemary kennedy drone eating oatmeal
you go yeah this is one of the kids that
we just let loose for the military
here's one of the stranger things kids
raise them
by the way when does that [ __ ] show come
back oh i saw the next season was uh by
the way
stop pretending you care about ozark
by the time ozark comes back
i'm gonna watch it
but
don't ever mention ozark
in the same way in the same sentence as
the sopranos again i will i will kill
the person who does that
mentions it in the same sentence as the
wire
ozark it's a clown festival the
writing's atrocious and the acting
lauralini and bateman do a great job the
kids do a good job too but the writing's
goofy it's downright silly
one of the kids is a fan of the show or
used to be
the meth kid
the tall skinny kid who looks uh
you know looks like he's a meth head
yeah yeah
and the girl listening to the show too i
think with uh the one who looked kind of
like laura linney okay but the reality
is
it's not good the show's not good and
none of you should have careers after
that in my opinion
none of you should have careers
stranger things when does this come out
it says 2022 who gives they're all 38.
they're all 40.
yeah what is it millie bobby brown how
old is she now i don't know she's she's
like elder 17 though
she's elderly
you know i don't like that finn wolford
i don't trust him
finn wolford yeah he's oh this guy yeah
i don't like it
i just don't trust him
he's untrustworthy
i don't know why
yeah i don't treat he seems like someone
would steal from your house
and they seem like someone would take
things
he'd like take things that he didn't
even want
he has a look of someone who would take
things he didn't want or need and then
dispose of them later
i could be wrong and yet i never am i
never am when i said charlie dimiglio's
a pyromaniac and she's lighting fires
with homeless people in malibu i'm
probably correct
i don't know why
i like the fire i like to watch the
smoke
i'm sorry you've jeopardized everything
this whole [ __ ] family
you're supposed to dance and we make
millions of dollars
now you're [ __ ] starting fires in
malibu
i like to feel
and it makes me feel
no one no one knows i like the fires so
they can't they can't comment
they can't say she didn't even really
light the fire i bet she's fake i bet
the fires she didn't even light it i bet
someone else slid in
i can't [ __ ] believe this my
daughter's and fire is a malleable
i hope
i hope to god she is
what if
charlie dimiglio immediately when she
was legal at 18 started dating o.j
simpson
like if they hey demilia family you
probably don't listen to this i don't
blame you
but listen up if you want to be big
kardashian level big one of your
daughters has to date o.j
dixie
whoever
whenever they're legal they have to date
o.j simpson
dump that other kid
and date
o.j
if you want to hit show if you don't
want to hit show
oh dixie's 20. i thought she was the
younger one no she's older
and uh she needs to start dating o.j
simpson to make the show interesting
yeah yeah i would watch that every day i
would fight people
and lose maybe who prevented me from
watching that show
where o.j simpson
and dixie dimiglio dated
i mean it's got to be
legit
like i like oj like the father's gotta
be like oh jace he's nothing but good to
dixie
he supports a music career and the
mother's gotta be like you know he
supports her and my kids yeah i want
them supporting oj supports charlie goes
well
o.j is a lot older than dixie but he's
been like an older brother to me
he shows me how to throw a football
i really love oj
sometimes people on the internet say bad
things about oj
but i don't believe them because
sometimes people on the internet say bad
things about me
but i like oj
i can't believe it my daughter in malibu
they're saying you attacked a family
with a machete now you cut out some
guy's eye
no i did it
you have to believe me
well we all thought tick tock was going
to be over we all thought the pandemic
was over and here we are
fall of
2021 yeah these kids own our lives and
the pandemic we have uh a variant a week
here coming in so i guess it just never
ends you're living in the demelia
variant there's nothing you can do
tick tock's not going anywhere bryce
hall's gonna be elected the governor of
california
and uh there's just gonna be a new
variant every week so there's there's
nothing you could do
we're we're in uh we're in the future is
now we're here
it doesn't seem to be changing
but
hey
it's
what
we
deserve
truly
like
this is
the type of show
that you get
but and i don't even mind it i just have
ways to make it better
the father has to cheat on the mother
with and start banging an 18 year old
take doctor
dixie has to start dating o.j simpson
charlie has to start starting fires in
malibu with homeless people
that's what has to happen
little huddy has to admit he's actually
a vampire and that he can only
uh come if he's drinking blood he has to
admit that he has a blood fetish
then i will watch the show
timberlandcomedy.com our our big tour is
being announced in
two weeks
no a week a week it's being announced in
a week
uh tim littlecomedy.com grab those
tickets to corpus christi texas also
baltimore maryland at mcgoobies i
believe that's sold out god i don't want
to go there um i love it i'm kidding i
love it crab
uh
we've got a big deal uh
uh ontario california the ontario improv
uh that's a hellscape but but come out
there but we got a big theater in l.a
too we're playing the night after
thanksgiving i know i shouldn't be
announcing it but the night after
thanksgiving we have a very big theater
in l.a that we're doing we're very
excited to do it
so
it is what it is get those dates out of
here do you have anything to plug i
always plug everything i'm doing but i
forget that you have a very interesting
life
uh you can follow me on instagram at ben
avery's good you have breakdowns every
now and then where you like put up like
this is the drip and you put up like
you're in a shirt or something that was
funny
yeah
and then if you follow me on twitter
same handle uh i post usually links to
the patreon episodes there oh
good you gonna see your wife she's out
in l.a right now is she watching the
kids watching the kids but tomorrow
we're all gonna go to dinner me and my
brother you
don't tell people what we're doing
people know they're gonna show up
and try to kill me
for for
negatively talking about the and by the
way i don't even i just want to help the
demilia yeah yeah
i'm only trying to ever help
i want you to have a big show but you
have to let me help
man if oj came in and like helped start
the fire oh my god if oj
if dixie was singing to oj
and the song is called second chances
and she's like second chances you know
how dixie sings she's actually not a
horrible singer she's pretty decent and
she goes second chances
sometimes it's you know they write songs
in five minutes these idiots you know
the the people that write the songs they
just hand them to her on her phone and
she reads it she's like second chances
second chance has given us the address
to bring roland
second chances
i love you
and you just say oj just like singing
along he's just bobbing his head
and she's like i don't care what they
say about you
i don't care what they say that you've
done i love you
i love you so much second chances and
then oj's in the back just like yeah and
charlie's like dixie's really killing it
she's killing it and she's like and
she's like and then the series
it ends like this ready she's fighting
with her parents and she's like i'm
having oj's baby
[Laughter]
that's the way to [ __ ] wrap up a
season dixie goes i'm having oj's baby
and then o.j and o.j has to kill noah
back who she dates yeah yeah they take
that guy oh just to kill him but it's
not proven
and it's like she's like i don't care
that they say you killed noah back
he might have
so again
it's just i have so much creative
constructive criticism for that family
you know
if it ever feels like it's too much
you know and then then the father has to
still say that he still has to say that
once everything's crazy he doesn't mean
like dixie's dating o.j right yeah she's
having oj's baby
charlie's in jail for lighting the
malibu fire and the father has to look
at the camera and go you know if it ever
gets too much i'll just take him back to
connecticut
if it ever gets too much
but we're gonna get through it together
as a family
you know
uh grab some tickets folks
patreon.com the tim dillon show if you
want the bonus content we post one uh
episode a week on tuesday and then for a
higher tier we do an extra
uh
video episode uh every month as well
patreon uh dot com slash tim dillon show
amazed at the success on that and it's
how many people have connected with the
show and like the show and who knows
maybe this advice will get to the right
ears and something really good can
happen i hope so r.i.p
joe
i miss him i miss him dearly
but
this is what happens in life
in life
we all have challenges
right
and
it's hard
to know
what the route is going to be
no one knows the day it ends
you just live a good life while you're
here
isn't it the truth yeah it is you just
live a good life while you're here
and he did that
and
r.i.p to him and when spotify will
finally admit that he is not with us
anymore
um i'm sure we will do a uh a memorial
uh uh you know sure
jaco willink will speak
david goggins will run backwards through
the to the funeral
just david doggins running backward
jordan peterson just weeping
it's
there's nothing wrong with weeping it's
not a little weep he's just crying
michaela peterson there just sitting in
the front row eating salted pork snack
just eating you know dried meat
just staring at the casket
you know
tony hinchcliffe's sitting there in a
cowboy hat just a whole cowboy outfit
me and you
sitting there in the back
you know barry weiss
you know sitting there wrapped in his
the flag of israel
i mean just
you know
bernie sanders like [ __ ] this
guy endorsed me he endorsed the most
left-wing candidate for president ever
and then the elizabeth warren liberals
called him a racist transfo bernie just
shows up
you know
brendan schaub is there
everybody's there yeah you know
it's just i so i imagine that's what
will happen
when we can finally
when this information is uh
is out there would jamie be there
jamie is would be on the
run because jamie's lost his mind
do you think when joe retires jamie
thinks he's gonna get into the seat and
be like all right everybody let's go
now what you've been really waiting for
the jamie experience
no you pull it up
he turns around
he's like i bet in the studio like late
at night when joe's gone jamie just sits
in the chair and goes you pull it the
[ __ ] up
you pull it up how about that
you pull it up
i'm a mountain man
oh
all right folks
go find us on the internet goodbye